IS WILD.
CONTROVERSY IS SWIRLING AROUND
THE OBAMA PRESIDENT ALLY PRAYER
AND THE OBAMA CENTER IS GOING TO
CONTAIN NO BOOKS.
IT IS MORE LIKE A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPUS WITH A RECORDING STUDIO
AND LIKE HE DID SEVERAL YEARS
WITH THE KARAOKE AND IT IS GOING
THE DIRECTOR OF THE CULTURAL
FOUNDATION AND HE'S SPEAR
AND CHARLES, NO BOOK.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE THE ARCHIVES
ARE OR NO DOCUMENTS.
EXPLAIN THIS.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THANK YOU FOR
COVERING THIS STORY AND TAKING
THIS UP.
SO, TREMENDOUS KUDOS.
YOU ARE RIGHT, IT IS NOT A
LIBRARY.
PARKLAND THAT HAS BEEN HELD IN
TRUST FOR 150 YEARS HAS BEEN
OFFERED UP AND WE ARE SEEING AN
ENTERPRISE IN A PUBLIC PARKLAND
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
IT LOOKS LIKE SOME KIND OF
SPACESHIP AND IT IS NOT
ATTRACTIVE AND I'M GOING TO HAVE